I I'm a little obsessive with it so my
market maps are like pages and pages
long and we have kind of a market
mapping system where I'll Target clients
based on their location industry and the
tax tax that they typically hire for
it's all in bullhorn sorry all in
bullhorn all right okay cool every
candid that I speak to from a certain
site will go into my market map their
manager name their team name their
project information the skill set that
they used what problem they solved if
you get on a good rapport with a
candidate what they manager likes what
their sports teams are what their
interests out of work are cuz that stuff
all goes into getting referenc when I'm
reaching out